the real reason Charlie D'Amelio is done
with the hype house
tick tock stars Charlie and Dixie
D'Amelio have made the call to leave
pipe house for good but was this a smart
business decision or a much more
personal one we'll talk about their rep
statement and look at how it syncs up
with the trouble some of us saw coming
Charlie D'Amelio is oh come on we all
know who she is she's the most followed
star on tick-tock and the one who
managed to knock former reigning queen
Lauren gray off her throne she is over
55 million followers on the app and her
sister Dixie is hot on her heels with
over 23 million I think
it's surreal and up until recently
Charlie and Dixie were both part of the
collaboration of tick tock Raiders known
as the hive house losing Charlie and
Dixie was definitely a huge hit to the
hype house and fans want to know what
happened to cause the split but
according to representatives speaking on
behalf of the D'Amelio sisters this was
strictly a business decision Kern hi
how's member and co-founder chase Hudson
has always claimed that the collective
was created to cultivate a family vibe
he wanted fans to feel like they were
connected to something and wanted the
tick tock stars who participated to feel
like they were a part of a community
instead of just roomies sharing their
space and camera time a representative
speaking on behalf of Charlie and Dixie
claims that at some point I Foust
started to become more of a business
apparently that is the aspect of hype
house the sisters are stepping away from
not necessarily their relationships with
its existing members or at least that's
what their representative says even
though Charlie and Dixie always look
like they're having a blast in their
videos they're also making money and
marketing themselves as a business and
it's possible they're dreaming so big
hype house just can't keep up with them
could the D'Amelio s be the next
Kardashians you might be keeping up with
the D'Amelio sooner than you think
because they're talking about creating
their own reality show according to
Charlie and Dixie their fans love seeing
their family dynamic and tuning into
their Instagram lives people see what
goes on when we're not just posting
Charlie thinks making a reality show
would be a great way to stay in touch
with their fans while also having a
great time
even our parents are on board and say
that if they're going to go for it then
they want to go all-in which sounds an
awful lot like what Kris Jenner says
about the star
of keeping up with the kardashians lil
Hadi says the hype house is like a
family but it seems like this reality
show would focus on Charlie and Dixie's
biological family so that could be part
of the business decision that led to the
sisters stepping away from Heights house
if they want to focus on their own
careers instead of collaborating with
their roommates then leaving seems like
a simple next step
Charlie loves showing off her skills and
lip syncing and dancing but it seems
like she's ready to take her career up a
notch even if it means leaving some of
her former friends behind at least
creatively their rap did say that
Charlie and Dixie are trying to separate
their business and personal
relationships meaning that just because
they're no longer part of the hype house
family it doesn't mean they aren't still
friends with those they left behind news
of a possible D'Amelio reality show is
definitely exciting and it's also way
more of a surprise than their exits from
the hype house detail-oriented vans have
been suspecting for quite some time that
a split was in the works so let's take a
look back at the lead-up to this
decision one big warning sign they were
starting to step away from the
collective was the fact that they
weren't out there repping their merch
yes if you didn't already know you can
buy tons of cool highs house swag
something its members weren't shy about
showing off on social media with two
exceptions Charlie and Dixie were
conspicuously absent when it came to
advertising the latest hype house
collection which many fans felt was
suspicious the D'Amelio sisters
definitely keep themselves busy but
promoting the hype house brand should
have been the priority at least if they
were planning on remaining with the brew
it was right around this time in April
2020 that fans also noticed Charlie and
Dixie weren't just missing in the merch
promos they were also absent from the
hype house's Instagram stories usually
the hype house account keeps fans
updated with what their members are
doing online but there was nothing about
Charlie or Dixie for weeks despite the
fact that they were definitely active on
social media this definitely seemed like
a major red flag but some fans were
understandably skeptical that they were
really leaving after all when former
member Daisy Keach left the hype house
Instagram account unfollowed her
immediately
since the D'Amelio were still being
followed though not featured it wasn't
conclusive proof that their arrangement
had changed in any way
and that goes both ways since both
Charlie and Dixie were still following
the hype house at this point in fact
even though their departure is official
a high pass and the D'Amelio are still
connected via Instagram accounts this
definitely seems to support their rep
statement that they parted on good terms
and intend on remaining friends with
those they left behind another major
warning sign was this tick-tock
slideshow featuring members of the hype
house
it didn't take dance long to notice that
Charlie and Dixie weren't in a single
one of these photos at the time the
D'Amelio were in quarantine with their
parents but a lot of these images were
taken way before that started it was
clear they could have been a part of the
slideshow but were intentionally omitted
for some reason even though the official
explanation is that this was a business
decision
many fans wonder why Charlie and Dixie
were so quiet about their departure why
drag it out over weeks and leave
seemingly obvious evidence like the tick
tock slideshow it could be that Charlie
and Dixie were just taking care of the
practical end of their departure and
wrapping up the ramifications of them
leaving before going public or this
could have been an attempt to minimize
the amount of drama their exit from hype
house would inevitably cause we've seen
how things are going with Daisy key so
it wouldn't be surprising if that's a
situation Charlie and Dixie are trying
to avoid Daisy situation aside there's
another even bigger potential catalyst
for drama and that's the fact that
Charlie D'Amelio and chase Hudson used
to be in a romantic relationship with
one another this is also one of the
major reasons so many fans suspected the
sisters would be leaving the hype house
and it's not hard to see why they
started showing up together on Tik Tok
in November 2019 but it was hard to tell
if they were just collaborators or
something more when Charlie posted this
sweet snap on Instagram in December 21st
2019 fans couldn't help but notice that
the two were posing like they might be
more than just friends despite being
caught holding hands at Target the most
romantic activity there is it took them
some time to officially announce their
relationship Charlie insisted she wasn't
seeing anyone while sharing romantic
pics like this an insisting she was
taking it slow finally they made things
official on Valentine's Day by sharing
sweet coordinating posts on Instagram
isn't that what
is really about everyone Charlie all the
guys are just gonna hit me because they
love Charlie but one of the big reasons
so many fans suspected Charlie and Dixie
were going to leave the hype house is
not only because this formerly sweet
couple split but because there were
rumors chase had cheated on Charlie
these kinds of accusations aren't
uncommon in high profile relationships
but they were pretty hard to ignore when
sway House members started making diss
tracks
according to sway House member Josh
Richards his girl friend and fellow
tick-tock user Nessa Barrett received
suggestive DMS and pictures from Chase
he and Bryce Hall collaborated on still
softish and the only real response we
got for a while was little hottie
tweeting that he knew it was only a
matter of time before someone made a
diss track about him chase eventually
posted that he had loved one girl and
one girl only and even Charlie's mom and
sister Carissa spoke out in support of
him even though the rumors of chase
cheating might not be true Charlie and
Lowe Hudy did officially split shortly
afterwards Charlie said she and chase
were still friends and that she cared
for him and wished him the best moving
forward and he shared a similar
sentiment with his fans although a
bitter breakup would be a perfect
explanation for Charlie's hype house
exit this doesn't seem to be the case in
fact Charlie and chase are so friendly
on social media that some fans even
suspect they've gotten back together on
the down-low and aside from the
situation with Chase both Charlie and
Dixie seem to still be on good terms
with their former hype House members if
there are any feuds they're keeping it
as quiet as they did their gradual
departure from the house itself
now that Charlie and Dixie are leaving
you might wonder what's next for this
collaborative effort just because
they're down a couple of members right
now doesn't mean they're breaking up for
good
so if you've invested in some of that
hype house merch go ahead and hang on to
it
according to member and co-founder
thomas Petro he believes the hype house
will live past himself and its current
members that new creators will join as
more experienced ones leave having used
type house as a stopover on the road to
fame
according to Addison Rae when she first
joined up she had about 2.8 million
followers and now she's grown to 39
point seven million
Thomas claims people are always trying
to join hype house to promote their
content but its intention is to inspire
creators and promote collaborations not
just to give people their 15 minutes of
fame during an interview with Forbes in
February 2020 time aside he expects the
next generation of tick stalkers will
take over the house in the next five
years so while Charlie and Dixie leaving
may seem sudden to their fans it could
really be part of the team's long-term
plan the goal isn't to stay in Heights
house forever it's to take what you
learned there and apply it to your
future career there's also been
speculation that Addison Rae is either
leaving or has already left the hype
house although nothing is confirmed yet
she could be ready to move on just like
Charlie and Dixie if Thomas is right and
it's just a matter of time before
Addison and other existing members leave
and that isn't necessarily a bad thing
while hype house is losing some of the
current biggest tick tock stars don't
forget that even people like Charlie
once started out with just a few fans
instead of the hype house totally
collapsing after the loss of Charlie and
Dixie it will now have room for new
members to join be inspired and take
part in some amazing collaborations with
seasoned tik-tok stars do you think
Charlie and Dixie are leaving the hype
house so they can move on to the next
step of their careers or is there
something else going on share your
thoughts and theories with us and your
fellow fans in the comment section and
don't forget to click that subscribe
button for more videos from the things
bye for now